the weather is going to be beautiful
this saturday morning for you to come
out and support a very special
fundraiser for children in our area with
rare diseases it's the vegas cares about
rare fundraiser it's in person this year
after a virtual run walk last year
this is going to be our sixth annual
vegas cares about rare 5k one mile
charity event this saturday's walk run
is one of the largest fundraising events
that supports the non-profit little miss
hannah foundation created in honor of
robert and kerry austria's youngest
daughter hannah who was born with an
ultra rare genetic disease that disease
has no cure and no effective treatment
so the time that we were with her for
three and a half years
it was all dedicated to making sure that
her quality of life was maintained was
the best it could be the couple created
the little miss hannah foundation to
help other families who are also caring
for kids with medically fragile
conditions rare diseases or in hospice
or palliative care fronts from this
weekend's event go to various grants
even medical equipment not covered by
insurance to help these other southern
nevada families it's amazing i'm still
getting a lot of facebook memories you
know from years past and you see the
pictures over the last couple of years
around this time and it's amazing that
it's you know this is our sixth annuals
our tenth year uh the support from
southern nevada has been you know
exceeded expectations for sure and each
year they give special attention to the
children with medically complex
conditions in our community as vips this
year 25 very important people will be in
attendance executive director and mother
to vip bradley jenny kershaw our kids
are treated like celebrities i say it
every year but there's no other event
like this
where
people you know family friends people
you don't know they're cheering you on
they're encouraging your child it's
nothing but love and just support and
encouragement and i'm getting goosebumps
right now just talking about it it
really really is and it's an amazing
event
it is and i'm so honored once again to
be the mc and kick things off for this
weekend's walk and run so come on out
join us this saturday morning at
cornerstone park in henderson the race
starts at 8 30. you can register online
go to vegascares.org
or just come register in person early
saturday morning before the race